moi je souffre et je souffrirais toute
ma vie toute ma vie je me méfie vous
manqué toute ma vie je vais pleurer leur
absence
ça ne m'empêche pas d'être profondément
en paix
[Musique]
je sais pas comment console bien j'ai
pas envie de donner bonne recette pour
consoler parce capable de manière
commune de console et c'est vraiment une
relation qui s'établit entre deux
personnes et qui s'ajuste aux deux
personnes qui sont l'une en face de
l'autre
ce qui m'a consolé ses skis console tout
par quelqu'un qui ose s'approcher par
exemple une nuit en pleine nuit à se
laisser hospitalisé dans un état très
critique je me retrouve dans un hôpital
perdu effrayer effrayé parce que j'avais
peur que ma fille meure et j'ai une
infirmière en milieu de la nuit qui est
arrivé qu'à vu mon désarroi qui s'est
assise à côté de moi mais sans le
toucher et qui m'a dit je suis là c'est
aussi ceux qui m'ont pris dans leurs
bras
alors ça chez moi j'insiste sur
l'importance du toucher la consolation
c'est une danse c'est un pas de danse on
est deux à danser ensemble de à
s'ajuster au pas de l'autre est au coeur
de l'autre celui qui souffre doit aussi
dire
moi je souffre je souffre et je
souffrirais toute ma vie toute ma vie je
me fie vous manqué toute ma vie je vais
pleurer leur absence ça ne m'empêche pas
d'être profondément en paix un peu parce
que je sais que cette souffrance à les
consoler le scandale c'est pas pour moi
c'est pas la souffrance et la souffrance
qui est pas consoler et moi j'ai été
accompagné j'ai été rejoindre j'ai été
aimée dans cette souffrance aussi et ça
ne m'a pas détruit son de boot garçons
debout quoi ils n'ont pas peur de la
souffrance
ils ont développé évidemment une
empathie qui est magnifique
j'ai été assez touché récemment parce
que un jour je vois là je me laisse
souvent submergé par cette souffrance
cette peine est comme beaucoup de gens
beaucoup d'enfants en tout cas ma mois
david d'accord j'ai quand je suis triste
je pleure je pleure parfois beaucoup et
récemment gaspard dont kim crise mais je
pleurais j'étais triste et il est venu
et m'a consolée il m'a pris dans ses
bras et mains serrées comme je n'aurais
jamais pu imaginer qu'il ne sert autant
et après m'a dit maman je te
conseillerai toujours comme tu m'as
consoler
ne t'en console pas la consolation c'est
une action c'est quelque chose d'actifs
c'est une intention c'est une volonté
le temps a passé de volonté là le temps
passe et en effet ou d'un certain temps
les souvenirs vont s'effacer
la peine sera moins présente au
quotidien mais quand elle arrive moi
quand je suis envahi peine c'est avec la
même intensité qu à l'instant de la mort
de mes filles quasiment enfin ça me
terrasse à chaque fois mais c'est moins
fréquent
ça fait maintenant 13 ans que thaïs est
mort trois ans quasi lycée morte
je ne peux pas dire que je souffre aussi
souvent mais aussi le temps et a été
compliqué à gérer parce qu'avec ce temps
qui efface la douleur il efface aussi
les soutenir
il efface aussi le visage de mes filles
il efface une ce qu'ils avaient imprimé
en moi et ça c'est très douloureux
jusqu'à ce que j'accepte et je vous dise
c'est comme ça c'est comme ça ça fait
partie de ce chemin de l'homme mais
n'oublie jamais le mot quota et n'oublie
jamais la manquons à partager sur tout
et puis je vais me replonge dans cet
amour vient m'a rappelé ce que j'ai vécu
et ce que j'ai ressenti mon rêve
e
[Musique]
je crois que ce que l'on veut n'a vécu
et qu'on continue à vivre avec cette
pandémie c'est le confinement c'est le
révèle c'est presque la seule chose dont
on soit qui est garantie dans la vie
c'est qu'on va mourir
et pourtant on n'arrive pas à en parler
on n'arrive pas à l'affronter on
l'éloignent de la société aux normes
tout ce qui touche la mort on
l'encadrent on légifère sur la mort n'en
est plus capable de lui donner une vraie
place dans la société de la regarder
telle qu'elle est elle dit notre
finitude il dit aussi peut-être qu'il ya
quelque chose de plus grand que l'homme
elle nous invite à nous interroger de là
dessus et ça nous pose un problème
visiblement moi je suis très étonné de
voir par exemple que les enfants vont
plus aux enterrements
non mes enfants ils ont évidemment
assister à l'enterrement de leur soeur
gaspard pendant la cérémonie faisait des
avions en papier qui balançaient au
dessus du cercueil
certains s'en sont peut-être refus ce
qu'est et voilà il disait j'espère
qu'elle en attrape rhin s'est il a us il
a assisté à l'enterrement de sa soeur
comme un enfant il n'a pas été
traumatisé il a su la réalité de sa mort
il a compris d'été là à ce moment que je
déteste de la mise en terre mais qui est
une réalité aussi et ça lui a permis lui
aussi de comprendre à quel point c'était
vrai et ça faisait partie de sa vie
quand on dit aux enfants
ton grand père est parti
qu'est ce que ça signifie en ébranlant
quelque chose de très naturel qu'elles
sont donc que notre rapport instinctif à
la mort quand on est enfant on n'a pas
perdu
j'ai eu récemment le message
bouleversant d'un père qui est perdu sa
fille jeunes adultes et qu'ils disaient
plus personne ne prononce son mot son
prénom il a il a fini sa phrase et
ensuite il a juste écrit les lettres de
son prénom et je me suis dit ce prénom
là qu'on a choisi qu'on a donnée qui
représente la personne toute entière
cette ce prénom là qu'on aime je pense
qu'on est quand même nombreux avoir
envie de l'entendre prononcer à nouveau
non pas pour ressusciter un enfant qui
est mort on sait qu'il ma mémé pour pour
ne pas le faire disparaître totalement
pour ne pas que cette enfant soit devenu
un tabou cette enfance à sa mort et puis
aussi la souffrance que l'on éprouve cet
homme en fait il parlait de la mort de
sa fille et beaucoup de souffrances mais
il semblait souffrir encore plus du fait
qu'on ne prononce plus monde sa fille et
donc je lui ai répondu en mettant je
pense cinq fois volontairement dans un
message le nom de sa fille pour les as
je vais me prononcer je vais le le
déguster avec vous je vais le savourer
avec vous ce prénom
et puis j'ai eu un message qui m'a
beaucoup plus verser de quelqu'un qui
m'a dit j'ai vécu un drame il ya des
années et j'ai réussi a pleuré à la
lecture de votre livre
ce drame que j'avais vécu
[Musique]